Justice Anthony Kennedy steps down and
the world goes insane i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is now in order I'm not
saying that I have inside information on
who the president's going to pick or
anything like that I'm not saying
anything like that I'll give you all the
updates on the news and we'll go through
what this means the Justice Anthony
Kennedy who as I have said many times on
this program made up his mind on how to
vote based on whether he had his
Metamucil that morning he's gonna step
down I'll explain everything that means
in just a second first don't remind you
that we have a special livestream this
coming Monday July 2nd 7:00 p.m. Eastern
will be joined by special guest Jordan
Peterson to celebrate Independence Day
God King Jeremy boring will host a new
edition of daily we're backstage with me
Andrew Clavin and Michael Mills to look
back on our country's birth and look
ahead to its future with the world's
most prominent Canadian subscribers
we'll even be able to write in live
questions for us to answer on the air
again that is Monday July 2nd 7:00 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific with Jordan
Peterson you can find our special live
stream on Facebook and YouTube so don't
miss it and if you haven't heard this
already I will be taking the Ben Shapiro
show live to audiences in Dallas in
Phoenix this August you'll be able to
see me in person and join an audience
Q&A tickets are going fast visit daily
wired.com slash events to get in those
last ticket orders right now daily
wire.com slash events to get your
additional seats and info already so
Before we jump in first let's talk about
life insurance now normally if you're
sitting on the Supreme Court you stay
there until you die Anthony Kennedy
however did not but we all at some point
will pass and when we do it will be a
good idea for us to have had life
insurance because 71 percent of people
say they need life insurance the real
answer is 100 percent of people if you
have family if you have people who you'd
like to benefit if you die the policy
genius is the place to go because it's
the easy way to compare life insurance
online you can compare quotes in just
five minutes when it is that easy
putting it off becomes a lot harder you
can compare quotes while sitting on the
couch watching TV or while listening to
this podcast so go check it out policy
genius com they don't just make life
insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renter's insurance and health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so if you need life insurance
but you've been putting it off check out
policy genius that's policy genius calm
there's no sales pressure there's zero
hassle and it is free again there's no
reason for you not to have life
insurance the fact is that if something
should happen to you and you leave your
family without any sort of financial
recourse that is your own fault and
there's no excuse for it check out
policy genius.com when it's this easy to
compare life insurance no reason to put
it off policy genius
calm okay so yesterday after we finished
this podcast Anthony Kennedy stepped
down and blew up the world so I was not
expecting Justice Anthony Kennedy to
step down from his position on the
Supreme Court and the fact is that I
think most people were hit by a truck
over this way most people in the Trump
administration were very surprised by
this and maybe President Trump was not
because maybe be having discussions with
Justice Kennedy but there are a lot of
people who are very surprised by Justice
Kennedy stepping down specifically
because most of his legacy is going to
be the gay rights stuff right he was the
lead writer in in obergefell which was
the case that suggested that same-sex
marriage had to be the law of land he
was socially liberal on issues like
abortion but he stepped down while Trump
was president and there was a Republican
Congress and that cut against a lot of
the conventional wisdom I for example
thought that he was going to stick it
out until there was a Democrat who was
presidents that his legacy would be
maintained but instead he decided to
step down the reason I think he decided
to step down besides the fact that he's
81 years old is because I think that he
looked at the spate of rulings that the
Supreme Court has issued over the last
three weeks and what he saw was that
there are four votes to overturn a lot
of First Amendment protections there
been three major cases in the last
couple of weeks in which five to four
the Supreme Court had decided in favor
of free speech but if he were to be
replaced by somebody from the left then
the left would immediately curtail the
right to free speech so for example
there was a case that I discussed at
length yesterday on the podcast this
case in which the Supreme Court decided
that you could not be forced to pay into
a union for which you did not vote and
Anthony Kennedy was on the majority side
of that opinion he said that that was
violation of the First Amendment well
there are four votes to say that the
government can force you to pay money to
an association like the Union that you
don't want to pay into right Anthony
Kennedy probably looked at that he said
I'm not sure that I want to leave one of
Democrats in office because then
there'll be five votes in favor of the
proposition that the government can
force you to pay money to an association
that you don't like and then there was a
case that came down in the last couple
of weeks in which for example it said
that mastered the masterpiece cake shop
case where it said that if you are a
religious Baker you do not have to bake
a cake for a same-sex wedding but only
this was decided on narrow grounds only
because the regulation in question was
badly promulgated by the Colorado Civil
Rights Commission there are four votes
in that case to basically suggest that
any
Baker in the country can be forced at
point of government gun to cater a
same-sex wedding and Anthony Kennedy
even though he's a gay rights advocate
might not be the kind of guy who wants
the government to force people to do
what they don't want to do at point of
gun until you figured okay if I stepped
down with a Democrat as president then
there will be five votes for the
proposition that the government can
force any religious person in the
country to violate his or her
prescriptions when it comes to business
so I think Anthony Kennedy looked at the
radical left of the court he said I
don't want my legacy to be the radical
left of the court
I'd rather rather than my legacy be the
gay rights legacy my guess is that he
wants to Chief Justice Roberts and he
got a guarantee from him that Roberts
would become the new swing vote if
same-sex marriage were to come back up
for reconsideration and Roberts will
work to to tamp that down that the
same-sex marriage stuff will stay
enshrined in law and his legacy will be
enshrined and he'll be fine and he will
be able to step down from the court and
be replaced by somebody who is more in
line with his thinking on First
Amendment issues now all of that is
speculation but that is my strong
inclination is that that's what happened
here in any case the Kennedy steps down
and that of course opens up a slot on
the Supreme Court and a swing vote on
the Supreme Court because Kennedy has
been the swing vote Kennedy has been the
guy who makes the decisions in these
five four cases he's been the most
powerful guy in the country for a long
time and that is a testament to the fact
that the Supreme Court has become far
too powerful in American life you saw an
enormous amount of gnashing of teeth and
wailing and rending of garments from the
left and tremendous excitement from the
right at the fact that this seat is now
open on the Supreme Court and Trump is
going to get to fill it and the reason
for that is that the Supreme Court has
become entirely too powerful in the
structure of American government if you
go back and you look at the Federalist
Papers we go through them every week
here on the bench Shapiro show when you
go back and you look through the
Federalist Papers what you see is that
they thought that the judiciary was
going to be a relatively powerless arm
of the government that its job was
basically going to be to sit there and
say this is constitutional and this is
not but not on the grounds they don't
like a piece of legislation in fact the
Federal Constitution didn't even apply
to the States
so the federal courts and the Supreme
Court in particular we're supposed to be
relatively toothless now the Supreme
Court gets to decide whether everyone in
the country is able to obtain an
abortion there is able to kill babies
the Supreme Court gets to decide whether
anyone in the country is able to get
married to anybody else the Supreme
Court has entirely too much power and
that is reflected in all of the focus on
the Supreme Court that's because the
left has taken the Supreme Court and
used
as a tool in order to promulgate its
agenda the left sees the Supreme Court
as its chief tool in pushing legislation
to get camp it can't get passed through
popular means the reality is the left
was pushing same-sex marriage for
example for years and years and they
weren't getting anyplace with regard to
federal legislation so they went to the
courts and the courts gave them what
they wanted and the same thing was true
on abortion well because you rely on the
courts when the courts flipped to the
other side there's now a lot of power in
in the in the hands of the right we'll
talk about what that means and what the
courts should be doing in just one
second first I want to point out that
you know some of us have been dreaming
of being on the Supreme Court our entire
lives so mr. president if you're
listening to this I would just remind
you that when 12 year-old Ben Shapiro
was playing at the Israeli bons banquet
in 1996 Larry King talked specifically
about the dreams of that young man hero
is 12 years old he'll be accompanied by
his father David he began training in a
violin at age 5 in addition to the vile
any place chess loves baseball completes
in track and field his goal is to become
the first Orthodox rabbi to sit on the
Supreme Court meaning of court court
we'll have to close at 3 o'clock on
Friday so I'm not saying that it's
something that I would I would take
something see job that were offered to
me I would take I'm not saying that both
an Coulter and David Limbaugh said in
2005 when I was still at Harvard Law
School I should be on the Supreme Court
I'm not saying that I'm 34 years old and
I'd be on the Supreme Court for the next
60 years mr. president but if you chose
to make that pick would I turn it down I
don't know I don't know I mean it's not
like I'm I don't know I'm not that
enthusiastic about it I mean but but
okay in any case in any case Mitch
McConnell says that the vote is going to
come this fall that this fall there will
be a vote on president Trump's
replacement justice and you can you can
just see the Glee on rich on cocaine
Mitch's face so Mitch McConnell is
snorted a full line and then he went
into Capitol Hill and this is what Mitch
McConnell sounds like when he's very
very excited about something the Senate
stands ready to fulfill its
constitutional role by offering advice
and consent on president Trump's
nominate to fill this vacancy we will
vote to confirm Justice Kennedy
successor this fall okay that is amped
up Mitch McConnell right there that is
Mitch McConnell on an 11 on a skeleton
he's got that spinal tap
yeah that spinal tap volume turned all
the way to the top and look Mitch
McConnell deserves a lot of credit for
this because it was Mitch McConnell who
said I am NOT going to move forward on
the nomination of Merrick garland and he
stood strong in the face of a lot of
press attacks and it's Mitch McConnell
who is largely responsible for the fact
that there will be two picks for the
President of the United States President
Trump says he is going to pick from the
current list which makes a lot of sense
he has a list of 25 possibilities there
are top five that I'm going to explain
in just a few minutes here I'm going to
go through the people who are being
looked at with the most scrutiny
according to Fred Barnes over the Weekly
Standard will talk about how a justice
should be selected but here as President
Trump saying that he's gonna pick from
the current list unfortunately there are
those of us who are not on the list
but president Trump says that he will
pick from the list that he's got already
have to replace himself obviously we
have a list of and president Trump also
said last night at a big rally last
night and he said that he was honored
that Kennedy chose to step down on his
watch that he chose to do it during my
term in office because he felt confident
in me to make the right choice and carry
on his great legacy that's why he did
one of the things that's amazing about
President Trump you really have to you
have to admire the man has the devil's
luck I mean there's just no question
that he has incredible luck now that
doesn't mean he doesn't have skill I
mean the president is very skilled at a
good many things but he's also damn
lucky I mean the fact is that George W
Bush in his entire eight-year term in
office got to replace two justices
President Obama and his entire
eight-year term in office got to replace
two justices neither of them swing
justices President Trump gets to replace
two justices in the first year and a
half of his term whereas an amazing
amazing thing and one of those is
Justice Kennedy who's a swing justice
now President Trump was lucky enough to
have Jeb Bush to beat up out on the
primaries and then get two billion
dollars of free media coverage he was
lucky enough to run against the worst
candidate in American history who was
under full FBI investigation and a week
before the election it was revealed that
she was under renewed FBI investigation
President Trump was lucky enough to be
there when Kim jong-un accid
we blew up his own nuclear mountain and
now he is lucky enough to be there when
Justice Anthony Kennedy steps down so
you know lefty Gomez famous New York
Yankees pitcher once said it's better to
be lucky than good it's better to be
both lucky and good president Trump is
definitely lucky and he certainly has
the opportunity to be quite good here
now
how should justices be selected right
how should we determine which justices
should be selected because the fact is
Republicans have blown opportunity after
opportunity on the Supreme Court I may
be the only conservative in America who
came out against the nomination of Judge
Roberts for Chief Justice Roberts
way back when way back in 2005 when when
Bush nominated Roberts I opposed Roberts
because I said the man did not have a
long track record of textualism and
originalism and he wasn't on record
supporting strong textualist positions
when it came to controversial cases and
anybody who is not openly conservative
and I don't mean conservative in the
sense that they're politically concerned
but anybody who's not textualist or
originalist which I'll explain in just a
second those people tend to move to the
center relatively quickly and I'll
explain why that matters in just second
first I want to talk a little bit about
zip recruiter so your business needs to
get better right you need to recruit a
new justice to the Supreme Court so
where do you look well you could rely on
your friends you can rely on people that
you know to recommend somebody for a job
or you could actually canvass the entire
country for the best candidates and
that's why you need sip recruiters sip
recruiter learns what you're looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and then invites them to
apply to your job 80% of employers who
post a job on zipper career get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day and zip recruiter doesn't
stop there
they even spotlight the strongest
applications you receive so you never
actually miss a great match the right
candidates are out there and zip
recruiters how you find them businesses
of all sizes trust the prakruti for
their hiring needs is why we use zipper
corridor here at the Daily wire right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free so go to zip recruiters comm
slash daily wire that zip recruiters
comm slash daily wire you can try it out
for free zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire again there's a reason that we use
it here at the office and there's no
reason for you to waste a lot of time
sifting through a bunch of bad resumes
when you can have zip recruiter
basically do it for you
zip recruiter knew there was a smarter
way they built a platform that finds the
right job candidates for you go check
them out right now zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire they are the smartest
way to hire again zip recruit comm and
when use that slash daily where you can
try zip recruiter for free ok so when it
comes to
election of Justices here's what you
need you need an open and obvious
commitment to originalism in textualism
originalism and textualism are the basic
notion that when you read a text when
you read the Constitution of the United
States you are not reading poetry it is
not a living document where you get to
reinterpret the provisions as you see
fit that day that's not what the
Constitution was for and you wouldn't
interpret any other piece of legislation
that way you wouldn't take the Sherman
Antitrust Act in 1907 and take that take
that piece of legislation and then say
you know what I think the Sherman
Antitrust Act means that gay marriage is
now legal because the document evolves
okay that's not how documents work the
whole point of writing something down in
a document the whole point of
legislation is that it is a piece of law
promulgated at a particular time with a
particular meaning in a particular place
and if you want to change that meaning
and you can always pass it another piece
of legislation you can have a
constitutional amendment for example
this is why the Constitution has so many
amendments because it needs to be
changed in many ways the fact is that
the Constitution of the United States
does not explicitly prohibit for example
women from voting but the Supreme Court
didn't just go back and reinterpret the
Constitution and say the Constitution
now means women can vote there's a
constitutional amendment that had to be
passed in order so that women could vote
because that's how legislation works the
way legislation works is that it is the
legislature that should be doing the
legislating it is the job of judges to
look at the text see what it means not
what they wish it meant now what they
hope it meant not what they would like
it to mean but what it actually meant at
the time that it was written and then
they implement that text and again if
you want to change that text well that's
why you have a legislature that's why
you have an elected branch of government
the left doesn't believe in this the
left believes that reading a text as it
is meant to be read is instead an
exercise in conservatism it's an
exercise in judicial activism to read
the Constitution as it was written now
if that sounds backwards to you it's
because it is it's stupid it's the idea
there should be an oligarchy that rules
us from above and gets to determine what
everything means in their own heads so
the latest example of that I mean the
overall decision that Kennedy decided is
a great case of this where Kennedy
looked at the 14th amendment of the
Constitution which was about preventing
discrimination against black people and
said the 14th Amendment to the
Constitution mandates that a man can
marry a man all across the country now
maybe you believe that a man should be
able to marry a man that's your
prerogative vote for a legislature that
says it's fine that's fine but to you
the idea the
judge is going to determine that from a
document that was written in 1917 89
right and a bill of rights that was that
was promulgated in 1791 and you're going
to take that document and reinterpret it
to me whatever you think it ought to
mean that is a fundamental breach of
judicial duty and that's why when we
look at the judges what we should be
looking at is who is going to implement
the Constitution as written that's their
job bro what conservatives want is for
the is for the judge is for the the
judiciary the Supreme Court to bring
back its focus to what it was supposed
to do for the Supreme Court to be just
as constrained as it originally was what
the left once the Supreme Court to do is
implement leftist values okay so how
does this play out well let's talk about
some of the let's talk about some of the
potential nominees that President Trump
is considering so according to Fred
Barnes over at the Weekly Standard the
White House is now narrowed down its
list of potential Supreme Court nominees
to a top five Brett Kavanaugh who's 53
on the DC Circuit Court of Appeals
I'm Wolf appar who is 49 on the Sixth
Circuit Amy Barrett who's 46 on the
Seventh Circuit Thomas Hardiman 52 on
the Third Circuit and Raymond Catholic
51 on the Sixth Circuit so all these
folks are relatively young you figure
that all of them will spend probably 30
years on the court barring serious
health problems this is why the idea
that Trump gets to shape the court for a
full generation here is exactly right
now all of that assumes of course that
Chief Justice Roberts isn't going to
become a Kennedy like swing vote which i
think is the dubious assumption but it's
possible that you may actually have a
conservative majority on the Supreme
Court for the first time in legitimately
generations so here is what we know
about the people who are being discussed
Brett Kavanaugh is apparently the
front-runner he is also the person who
is the most I see okay so I I do not
think the president should select Brett
Kavanaugh of the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals
he's a former clerk for Justice Kennedy
he was elevated to the federal bench in
2006 after a three-year delay the reason
his nomination was delayed was because
Democrats were upset over the fact that
Cavanaugh used to work for Ken Starr in
the office of the Solicitor General and
he had the temerity to say that the
Clinton administration targeted a Ken
Starr so Cavanaugh has been on the court
for quite a while his long record he's
offered about 300 decisions
he recently dissented when the circuit
decided that a seventeen-year-old the
legal immigrant detainee had a right to
an abortion he said that the decision
was quote based on a constitutional
principle as novel as it is wrong he
held in 2011 that the Washington DC ban
on semi-automatic rifles and its gun
registration requirement were
unconstitutional under the Supreme
or teller decision which recognized that
the second amendments the Constitution
was an individual right all of these are
good decisions he also held that the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
structure was unconstitutional which of
course is true as well and holds
administrative decision making to a
minimum
hey Kavanaugh here here's where it
starts to get a little bit a little bit
dicey Kavanaugh like Chief Justice
Roberts is known for working across the
aisle he is on the downside apparently a
general believer in Chevron deference
Chevron deference is the idea that you
have these administrative courts these
administrative law courts that get to
decide your fate and you can't appeal
that directly to the judiciary so
administrative law courts exist in the
executive branch there's a whole branch
of thought that says Chevron deference
is stupid that if something is decided
by for example the EPA that is
reviewable by a judge because the EPA is
not a judicial system the EPA is a
regulatory system Kavanaugh reportedly
does not use textualist methods nearly
as much as conservatives might wish and
worst he upheld Obamacare and sisal
versus Department of Health and Human
Services as well as 7 Skye vs. holder in
which he may have actually crafted the
rationale that Chief Justice Roberts
eventually used in calling the Obamacare
penalties attacks remember that Chief
Justice Roberts rewrote Obamacare to
make it constitutional suggesting that
it was a tax rather than a penalty and
it appears that Kavanaugh may have
actually created that may have actually
created that rationale so I'm not saying
the Kavanagh would certainly be another
Chief Justice Roberts but I think it's
more likely he would be another Roberts
than another Gorsuch hey now a move for
par he's relatively he's relatively new
to the appellate courts he voted to
uphold Ohio's method of legal and
injection lethal injection and a
Michigan Government's meetings opening
with a Christian prayer he said that's
legal as well he's ruled that monetary
donations our form of protected speech
under the First Amendment now because
the pars record is relatively thin on
the court of appeals he's only appointed
in the last year and a half there's not
much to go on with regard to issues like
abortion and religious freedom with that
said Professor Brian Fitzpatrick of
Vanderbilt Law School described the part
is very Scalia like and very Thomas like
and sipar has criticized Richard Posner
as pragmatism Posner is on the Seventh
Circuit Court of Appeals and is a
terrible judge he criticized Posner's
pragmatism in judicial theory because
using pragmatism rather than text would
quote elevate judges to the position of
coal edges later which is exactly right
judges should not be legislating they
should be interpreting the law as it is
written he has is it textualist was
praised scalia himself so if i have to
choose
the par and Cavanaugh I choose the par
the best of the bunch it seems to me is
Amy Barrett so Amy Barrett is on the
Seventh Circuit Court of Appeals she was
a cause celeb you recall when Democrats
began suggesting that her Catholicism
was a bar to her ability to be an
objective judge and she was supposedly
so Catholic that she was gonna use her
Catholicism to rule in particular cases
she says that life begins at conception
she signed a letter from the Becket fund
criticizing Obamacare's requirement that
employers provide contraceptive coverage
calling it a quote grave violation of
religious freedom Barrett has written in
depth on Justice Scalia's originalism
she's evidence support for textualism as
well she clerked for Scalia so Amy
Barrett would just be first-rate she's
the youngest of the bunch she's a woman
and it would drive Democrats up a wall
because she's Catholic as well so I
think Amy Barrett is my number one
choice now in just a second I want to
get to the last two possibilities for
the Supreme Court according to Fred
Barnes these are the top five that we
are going through right here first I
want to talk a little bit about Dollar
Shave Club so let's talk about the fact
that you look like a schlub okay the
reason you look like a schlub is because
every time you go to the drugstore you
forget to pick up a razor or you forget
to pick up the right soap and then you
run out of it you're in the shower you
look around there's no soap or you're
about to shave and you realize that your
your razor blades are all blunt well you
don't have to do that okay Dollar Shave
Club makes sure you have everything you
need to get ready in the bathroom any
particular product that you want
they've got all right Dollar Shave Club
delivers everything you need they've got
a shampoo conditioner body wash
toothpaste hair gel even a wipe that
leaves your butt feeling tingly clean
I am a particular fan of their amber and
lavender calming body cleanser really is
phenomenal it is delightful it smells
just wonderful and it is calming indeed
I mean you may get the impression from
me then I am high-energy and a giant
stress ball of a human being well let me
tell you once I start using the calming
body cleanser I mean it's Zen in there
all of Dollar Shave Club products were
made with top-shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget and you will
feel the difference so the best way to
get started is for five bucks you can
get their daily essentials starter set
it comes with body cleanser and one wipe
travel ease those are the amazing butt
wipes the world-famous shave butter and
their best razor the six blade executive
keep the blades coming for a few bucks
more a month add in shampoo toothpaste
anything else you need for the bathroom
check it all out at dollarshaveclub.com
slash Ben that's dollarshaveclub.com
slash menus that slash Ben said they
know that we sitting in to get that
special deal okay so we've been going
through the five judges that President
Trump is looking at for the Supreme
according to Fred Barnes I'm hearing the
same thing from from the folks that I
know in the White House that these are
the judges who are being considered
so we've already gone through we've
already gone through Brett Kavanaugh of
whom I'm deeply skeptical
I'm Wolf apar who sounds good but his
records a little bit thin Amy Barrett
who is a who I think is a deep
textualist a deep originalist and would
be a very very solid pick
now he gets Thomas Hardman so Thomas
Hardman you recall was one of the last
twos down to Hardiman and Gorsuch from
lassie I opposed Hardman I supported
Gorsuch good for me that was right
gorynych has turned out to be a
tremendous justice I am very skeptical
of Thomas Hardman Leonard Leo who's one
of trumps chief advisors has described
Hardman as very much in the mold of
Justice Scalia well schooled on the
doctrines of originalism and textualism
but Hardman has never spoken openly
about originalism and textualism and
Ritter heard his judicial philosophy so
I need to hear his judicial philosophy
now in some cases he's done great he
stood against a New Jersey law that
required showing a justifiable need to
allow carrying a handgun publicly he
said that violated the Second Amendment
in another Second Amendment case he
specifically stated that the threshold
question in a second amendment challenge
is one of scope adding that the inquiry
quote reflects an inquiry into text in
history that sounds originalist but it's
it's still a little bit thin he also
hears here's where you die see he also
ruled that a plaintiff could sue for sex
discrimination on the grounds that he
was a male treated badly for being
effeminate thus broadening the class of
claims under title seven of the Civil
Rights Act so title 7 of the Civil
Rights Act says you can't discriminate
against someone on the basis of sex
he broaden that to include you can't
discriminate against someone on the
basis of their perceived effeminacy
which is not the same thing at all right
the whole point of title 7 is that men
can't discriminate against women in
employment that was the point of title 7
it's not that you can't discriminate it
may be bad but title 7 doesn't say
anything about you made fun of a guy's
shirt because you thought that it was
pink or something there's nothing in
title 7 about that he also has ruled to
strike down a fire department's
residency requirements which he termed
racially motivated in that particular
case he equated disparity with
discrimination by statistical modeling
stating quote minority workforce
representation that low suggests
discrimination that kind of logic is not
textualist or originalist if you look at
if you look at disparity and you
immediately jump to it must be
discrimination then I've got a problem
with your legal reasoning he also ruled
in favor of an illegal immigrant seeking
asylum on the grounds that he was
targeted by ms-13 there was a new
dilemma
and who said that he wanted asylum in
the United States and he was refused to
silence it he's being targeted by ms-13
in Honduras and he was refused to
Thailand because they said well the
government supposed to protect you down
there anybody targeted by ms-13 doesn't
just get to claim asylum in the United
States and Hardiman overruled that he
said that this guy got to claim asylum
Hardiman is also good friends with with
President Trump sister who sits on the
on this I believe the Third Circuit
Court of Appeals and and they are good
friends I'm skeptical of Hardman I don't
think the Hardman would be a strong pick
so that to two out of the four I think
would be great picks two would not be
particularly strong then we get to
Raymond Catholic so Raymond Catholics
like Cavanaugh is a former Kennedy Clerk
unlike Cavanaugh he's actually expressed
his judicial philosophy so in his
original confirmation testimony he said
I would make sure that the values I
would be enforcing if I were a judge are
not just my values then I'm not striking
something down simply because I don't
like it that is a counter majoritarian
aspect of our system of our system of
government I would start with the text
he also said before the Federalist
Society the quote the court tries to
find the best objective interpretation
of the statute based on the statutory
text and he said the job of the court
was to determine what is the meaning
that the citizens bound by the law would
have described to it at the time it was
approved
okay that's sort of definitional
originalism we don't have a lot in terms
of his in terms of his particular
decision-making we do know that in 2016
Catholic slammed the IRS for failing to
turn over materials necessary for
determining whether they discriminated
against conservative groups as far as
abortion we don't have much on Catholic
Catholic was the Judiciary Committee
counsel for Spencer Abraham when he was
a senator when Abraham was pushing for a
federal abortion ban so here's the
bottom line
most outspokenly textualist judges on
this list are Barrett and Thapar Barrett
by a long shot
Kavanagh has the most red flags Hardman
has red flags - we don't know enough
about Catholic at this point from his
rulings but his talk of judicial
philosophy is promising here is the
problem
since justices since judge Bork was
nominated in the 1980s and and Ted
Kennedy the worst of all Kennedys came
forward and started bashing the hell out
of Judge Bork and you know coined the
term working him right just went after
him and destroyed him on the public
stage since then there has been a
tendency by Republican presidents to
nominate people who are stealth
candidates to nominate people who do not
have a long historic record of
originalism and textual
and you're not even allowed to ask
people tough questions you're not
allowed to ask them whether you think
that Roe was wrongly decided right you
see this in judicial hearings all the
time in Supreme Court judicial hearing
somebody will say well was rolled
wrongly decided and the left uses it as
the litmus test if you say Roe was
wrongly decided they won't vote for you
well the right should have litmus test
too of course Roe versus Wade was
wrongly decided it's a garbage case it
is a it is one of the worst recent cases
in the history of the United States and
it in Coke AIT's a moral standard that
is simply not based in the Constitution
there's nothing in the Constitution that
grants a right to kill your baby in the
womb the founders would've been appalled
at such a notion the literally nothing
is there it said there's an emanation
from a penumbra that ends up what does
that even mean basically what that means
is they're a bunch of justices on the
Supreme Court who decided they felt like
legalizing abortion that day so they
went ahead and they legalized abortion
that day hey it seems to me that you
should be able to ask judicial nominees
we're going to be sitting on the court
for the next thirty years what they
think of critical cases that they should
be able to give honest answers to those
critical cases but because Democrats
have made it such a cause celeb to
destroy people over their positions on
controversial cases the easiest way of
getting on the court is to be a stealth
candidate who's never said anything
controversial and then we never have to
ask you about the things you've said
that are controversial here's my
recommendation there 51 United States
senators who are Republicans that means
that President and thanks to Harry Reid
which I'll explain in a moment President
Trump does not need 60 votes to get
anyone through the Senate so let's ask
every question we've got to ask
let's vet these candidates all the way
down to the ground we cannot afford to
blow this if we get another justice
Souter if we get another Sandra Day
O'Connor if we get another Anthony
Kennedy if we get another John Paul
Stevens this will have been a massively
blown opportunity a massively blown
opportunity
a historically blow on opportunity that
will not come around again because
there's this sort of ghoulish death
watch that happens on the Supreme Court
where we sit around waiting for somebody
of the other party to die but the
Supreme Court needs to be hemmed back
into its constitutional role and its
constitutional role is not to implement
stuff that I like or stuff that you like
it's constitutional role is to read the
Constitution and apply the words of the
Constitution clearly this is why for
example if I were gonna go off the board
here but still on president Trump's list
I would be going for Senator Mike Lee I
think Senator Mike Lee would be the best
pick of anybody that's been brought up
we know where he stands politically we
know where he stands constitutionally I
know where he stands constitutionally
because I've discussed the Const
with Senator Lee senator Lee is a deep
textualist a deep originalist and you
know that he would vote to constrain the
federal government's powers when it
violates the the Constitution of the
United States and he would also not use
his own political preferences as the
guideposts for determining what the law
allows so I like the idea of Senator
Mike Lee I know people are saying well
then you won't have that vote in the
Senate are you kidding
Utah Yeah right Utah's gonna point to
Democrat senator to fill Mike Lee's spot
no chance okay so if you want to
guarantee that this is a pick that goes
through and a pick that votes the way
that that justices should all be voting
then it should be Mike Lee Michael would
be the best pick of the people on the
list Amy Barrett would be the best pick
as far as I am concerned now in just a
second we're gonna talk about the
wailing and gnashing teeth from the left
because I have this right here this
leftist here's tumblr and it has been
refilling non-stop is the first time in
24 hours that it's not spilling over
onto the desk I've literally just left
it here and it's just overflowed and we
had to have a plumber come in in
everything and they couldn't stop at the
magical leftist tears were just flowing
into it I had to drink them hot there's
no time to let them cool that's had
that's how amazing was so if you want to
hear all of that all you have to do is
go over to Daley wire.com right now and
subscribe $9.99 a month get two
subscriptions two daily wired icon that
means you get the rest of this show live
the execrable michael the moles show
live
Andrew Clavin show live and it also
means you get to ask us questions in the
mailbag I have a mailbag tomorrow it'll
be awesome you want to ask those
questions make sure you go over there
and with the annual subscription for $99
a year you get this this leftist tears
hot or cold tumblr and as I say
sometimes the tears are so salty and so
rich and so sweet at the same time you
could experience that yourself if you
just spent the $99 to get the annual
subscription also please check us out
over at YouTube and iTunes please
subscribe and leave us a review we have
a Sunday special coming up it's going to
be great this week with Adam Carolla
stopping by on Sunday and it's a lot of
fun so check that out as well we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so the best part of all of this is how
we got here so the way that we got here
is that Democrats in 2013 decided that
they were tired of Republicans
filibustering judicial nominees now the
process of filibustering judicial
nominees did not start with Republicans
it started under george w bush
it started with democrats trying to
filibuster people like Miguel Estrada
who was nominated to the DC Circuit
Court of Appeals and when it came time
for Barack Obama to stack the courts
Republicans who had enough votes in the
Senate to stop him filibustered so Harry
Reid went forward and he said you know
what we need to get rid of the judicial
filibuster there will be no more
filibuster he's what's called the
nuclear option he went to the Senate
parliamentarian and got a ruling that
suggested that there would be no need
for 60 votes to shut down a filibuster
instead he just got a 51 vote vote on a
rule that would get rid of the
filibuster for judicial nominees and
Harry Reid celebrated it at the time
Harry Reid was excited about it at the
time here is Harry Reid he was asked
about changing the GOP he was asked
about changing the filibuster and
whether he was worried that maybe at
some point this would turn around and
bite him right on the ass and here is
what Harry Reid had to say about that
why in the world would we care we were
trying to protect everybody I mean do
they want simple majority of fine I mean
all these threats about we're gonna
change the rules more as Senator Schumer
said what is the choice continue like we
are or have democracy okay so he said
let him do it if the Republicans ever
get in charge let him do it oh yes
indeed let them do it and Mitch
McConnell cocaine Mitch Reni then when
the cocaine Mitch he he said at the time
looking exactly the same he said you're
going to regret this a lot sooner than
you think he looks a little more piqued
now because he's done a lot more coke
but here is Mitch McConnell saying the
Harry Reid you are going to regret this
an Orrin Hatch sitting in the background
looking just as alive that as he is now
here is Mitch McConnell you want to play
games set yet another precedent that
you'll no doubt come to regret say to my
friends on the other side of the aisle
you'll regret this and you may regret it
a lot sooner than you think
boo Mitch McConnell prophet you may
regret this a lot sooner than you think
indeed indeed Harry Reid tweeted this
out Harry Reid owned the libs yesterday
say Harry Reid tweeted out thanks to all
of you who encouraged me to consider
Phil about
reform it had to be done Harry Reid
owning the web's circa 2013 just just
wonderful just wonderful here's an
entire montage of leftists at the time
suggesting how much they loved the idea
of nuking the filibuster this is 23
Democrats and this president going to
war with their enemies finally this is a
move Democrats had to make Republicans
put them in a position where basically
Republicans were saying we are not gonna
honor the power of the president all
this really does is say the president
that we elected to actually run the
government gets to run the government
once the majority is blocked all the
time on relatively ordinary things it's
not going to tolerate the protection of
the minority Ted Cruz is sort of Exhibit
A for why the Democrats and why Harry
Reid did what they had to do what we had
in the Senate which likes to call itself
the world's greatest deliberative body
we had paralysis and said I think the
escalated use of the filibuster has more
or less made it obsolete on the other
hand the actual history of how the
filibusters used is mostly nasty ugly
and racist mostly what other political I
love it so much so they they couldn't
stand the fat the filibuster was the
worst thing that ever happened a it had
to be stopped it just had to be stopped
because it was so bad it was so bad and
then they stopped it and guess what yes
I can feel the weight of this right here
it grows in my hand the weight because
the tears are filling up it was here and
just in the last five minutes it's gone
all the way up to here soon it will
overflow President Obama at the time
said we need to eliminate the routine
use of the filibuster for judicial
nominees because come on guys we have to
stop this we nee we can't go on I can't
go on probably the one thing that we
could change without a constitutional
amendment that would make a difference
here would be the elimination of the
routine use of the filibuster in this
Senate
ahahahahahaha so forgive me for saying a
little bit of a shut-in Friday here but
um yes you you you all deserve this you
had it coming but the richest shred in
Freud came courtesy of people wailing
yesterday now listen I understand why
people are upset the fact is that when
you believe that an institution is
dedicated to the promulgation of your
political ideology and then that
institution might be hemmed back into
its constitutional boundaries where it
won't just declare the game
the law of the land based on nothing or
won't just declare that abortion is the
law of land based on nothing when all of
that happens then I understand why you'd
be upset but that's because you were
stupid about what you think the Supreme
Court should have been doing to begin
with this was not the job of the Supreme
Court but DNC members who thought that
they were basically Anthony Kennedy was
the last bastion of hope so
this audio broadcaster day of DNC
members legitimately wailing after
Kennedy announced his retirement and is
just delicious
oh yes people are going crazy yesterday
Tommy Vietor I got out of his van and
decided from from pod save America folks
he decided to tweet
fu-uck to which I tweeted back to him
Tommy get back in the truck
so they said Tommy Vietor really doing
yeoman's work there it is funny to watch
as Tommy viewers bosses legacy is Pete
on like a mattress in Moscow by a
russian prostitute it's pretty
astonishing and then the best tweet
yesterday was definitely from some Rando
named Matt ek who tweeted out literally
in tears haven't felt this hopeless in a
long time with Justice Kennedy leaving
we now have two options as Americans get
fitted for your Nazi uniform or report
directly to your death camp how do you
fight the darkness without light my
spark is going out hashtag SCOTUS yeah
yeah that's probably that's probably
gonna happen here is that the
constitutional boundaries will be
restored and then we'll make you into a
Nazi and put you in a death camp that's
not an exaggeration at all guys no is it
there some of us have been prone to
exaggeration about Supreme Court
decisions of the past I think my
reaction to the Obamacare decision well
I think I was right about the the
general reaction was probably overstated
on Twitter but at least I wasn't saying
that we were living in a Nazi death camp
so there's that in any case the the the
level of leftist ire is insane and the
proposed solutions to stopping this
just as wonderfully delicious so let's
get into how the left has decided that
they are going to hold up the nomination
of Kennedy's replacement so Chuck
Schumer the Senate Minority Leader he
says that he's begging Republicans now
that they should follow their rule what
exactly does he think was their rule he
thinks that Mitch McConnell said that we
shouldn't vote on a judicial nominee in
an election year well know what Mitch
McConnell said is you shouldn't vote on
a judicial nominee in a presidential
election year now I thought that rule
was stupid from the beginning I don't
think you should vote on in judicial
nominee you don't like if you don't have
to because why would you why would you
vote to confirm a bad Justice just
because that's the way things are
supposed to go that's not the way things
are supposed to go this is why the
Senate advises and consents they are not
mandated to give their consent but Chuck
Schumer says no no I'm gonna pretend
that what Mitch McConnell actually said
is that we can't vote on a justice in
any election year at all midterm general
we can't we get none there will never be
another vote on the judicial nominee
well now somebody remind me when was a
Lena Kagan confirmed all right that's
was in 2010 in a midterm election year
here's Chuck Schumer begging Republicans
not to clock him with the tool he gave
them back in 2013 along with Harry Reid
our Republican colleagues in the Senate
should follow the rule they set in 2016
not to consider a Supreme Court justice
in an election year okay so yeah that's
not gonna happen so congratulations to
you Chuck Schumer he handed the baseball
bat to the other side and now you are
just begging not to be clock with it
Kamala Harris she is of course the
leader of the crazy caucus of the
Democratic Party and she says it's time
to play hardball kid Matthew come play
some hardball now and the only problem
is that all they have at this point is
someone observed on Twitter is a wiffle
bat so good luck with that
here's Kamala Harris saying that somehow
using votes they don't have and a
filibuster process they themselves nuked
they're gonna try to work to stop this
are you guys gonna play hardball this
time and say we're not gonna let you
pass this you're not gonna rush this
through us in a few months
ID for election day based on every
conversation I've had with my colleagues
so far this afternoon everybody's
prepared to play hardball
they have no tools there's no way for
them to play hardball they don't have
the votes it ain't gonna happen so MA
Lizabeth Morin she was sending up some
serious smoke signals that she that she
was upset about this entire thing in
fact she she it sounds like she really
wants to refight the Battle of Little
Bighorn here Elizabeth Horne
so there are Native American senator
from Massachusetts who's not Native
American in any way it makes a mockery
of Native American background with her
claims that she is I hear she is
explaining that Donald Trump is about to
destroy the country wholesale this woman
taught at Harvard Law School when I was
there she was obnoxious then she's
obnoxious now Donald Trump has the
opportunity to remake the Supreme Court
for a generation a woman's right to
decisions over her own body are at risk
equal rights equal marriage is also at
risk this is the fight of our lives if
you want to be in this fight and now's
the time raise your voice raise your
voice raise your voice we do not want an
extremist judge on a United States
Supreme Court raise your voice as much
as you want gain you ain't got 51 votes
you ain't got a majority so listen
eventually this will all be turned
around and there will be it in time when
Democrats are in power again and will
suffer the same way the Democrats are
now the difference is that Republicans
aren't interested in the Supreme Court
becoming a tool of their political
agenda Republicans just want the Supreme
Court to go back to the original text of
the Constitution and read the
Constitution like any other law would
ever be read like the bankruptcy code
would be read it is Democrats who have
mandated that the Supreme Court is
supposed to read the Constitution as a
piece of leftist legislation written in
2017 it's absurd and you can see the
media response here is is so
over-the-top and crazy Comedy Central
you know the place for comedy they
tweeted this out thanks Justice Kennedy
supremely effed that's Allah that's
literally what they sweet it out so well
done there's so much comedy and you see
the comedy there's so great a comedy
these people and I know Trevor Noah also
lost his mind you said he it feels like
all hope is dead
yeah sure know all hope is dead for a
comedy on your show but here is Trevor
Noah I know this news is very painful
for a lot of people feels like for the
next 30 years America is gonna change in
a horrible direction in some ways it
feels like all hope is dead and nothing
can bring it back or alternatively you
could get people elected to office who
passed the laws that you like
alternatively you could vote
alternatively you could stop relying on
nine leftists on the Supreme Court to
pass your legislative agenda and you
could actually go and have that
legislative agenda passed by a bunch of
Democrats or you could whine about it
really loud and cry and whine you know
if Chris Matthews go out there and say
it's a mere dog I say
harbaugh yeah go Chris Matthew get
committee show coming you're all angry
I'm so angry to go Christmas go it's
time for Democrats to play hardball
I'm Chris Matthews urging them to do
just that it's time to play hardball
it's time for me stop coming out of the
show and I will finally go and buy a
comb because that's how serious I am
about this situation the reality is the
Supreme Court never should have been
this important it is Democrats who made
it this important it is leftist who made
it this important and now they are
reaping what they sell and it is well
well deserved okay time for some things
I like and then time for some things
that I hate so the thing that I like
today is a book called the hollow hope
by Gerald Rosenberg okay there are a lot
of people who believe that the Supreme
Court is the great hope for their agenda
that the Supreme Court is going to save
them the Supreme Court is going to make
the country a better place that they're
going to do justice there's a very
famous story about justice Oliver
Wendell Holmes that he was he was
deciding a particular case and he was at
a dinner party and he goes out from his
dinner party and he hops in his carriage
and he's about to ride away and some guy
starts running after him and and he and
and the guy starts screaming at him do
justice mr. Holmes do justice and Holmes
looks back and he says it's not my job
to do justice it's my job to enforce the
law yes this is correct
okay historically speaking for all the
talk about how the Supreme Court has
radically changed things people
radically overestimate how much the
Supreme Court has changed things it is
my belief that even if same-sex marriage
had not been passed on the federal level
by the Supreme Court of the United
States that is the direction that the
country was moving anyway it is my
belief that even without Brown versus
Board of Education the country would
have moved away from segregation in fact
Brown versus Board of Education happens
in 1955 it takes until 1964 and the
Civil Rights Act to forcibly desegregate
the south that's what the that's the
argument the Gerald Rosenberg makes
Gerald Rosenberg is not a conservative
he's professor I believe the University
of Chicago Law School and he writes a
book called the hollow hope can courts
bring about social change and his real
answer is no the courts cannot bring
about social change the best that they
can do is sort of lag behind and then
rubber-stamp the direction they think
the country is going anyway so the left
that wants to use the courts as their
tool of social change the answer is if
you want social change go out and make
social change don't rely on a bunch of
non-elected oligarchs who sit there for
life to make your agenda happen that's
not the job of the Supreme Court it is
the job of the Supreme Court to enforce
the greatest documents ever conceived of
by human beings and that of course
be the Constitution of the United States
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate so Jeffrey Toobin just made an ass
of himself on CNN and not not a great
shot so Jeffrey Toobin is legal analyst
and he is going crazy just like
everybody else in the media about how
the end of the world is nigh right he
the Democrats have all become that weird
guy from The New Yorker cartoons
carrying around the the placard that
says the end is here so here's Jeffrey
Toobin doing his the end is here routine
with Justice Kennedy gone it will be Mad
Max Beyond Thunderdome people will be
beating each other up it'll be a
massacres in the streets gay people will
be running from crowds armed with
pitchforks and torches abortions will be
unavailable for anyone I mean from his
mouth to God's ears here's what he says
about abortion you are going to see 20
states passed laws banning abortion
outright just banning abortion and
because they know that there are now
going to be five votes on the Supreme
Court to overturn roe v wade okay so
let's be straight about this roe v wade
does not mandate that abortion becomes
illegal again roe v wade if it were
overturned simply kicks this the issue
back to the states where was from
beginning so if you think abortion is
gonna be illegal in California you think
abortion is gonna be illegal in New York
or Massachusetts or a wide variety of
other lefty states you're out of your
mind
okay I'm gonna be illegal there might be
heavier restrictions in places like
Alabama and Mississippi and Texas and
those restrictions may conceive of
exceptions for life of the mother for
example which is probably the most
common exception but for for Jeffrey
Toobin to suggest that it's going to be
this hellscape where if you want an
abortion you can't get one it's just not
true first of all I wish it were true I
wish it were true but how about the left
can make its case in public see the
here's the thing the left doesn't
actually like democracy when the left
talks about how much they love democracy
and how this is going to impose on our
democracy some sort of burden the
reality is they can't get people to vote
for their policies so they want judges
to do it for them and when Jeffrey Tumen
whines about this
I don't see why Jeffrey Toobin value set
should government what people in Texas
think I don't see why my value set
should necessarily govern about people
in Massachusetts thing I think on the
issue of abortion it's a little bit
different because if you consider
abortion to be a form of murder then you
actually do require federal legislation
on these issues because it is the job of
the government to protect life liberty
and property and under the Fourteenth
Amendment
institution there's equal protection of
the laws which in my view should be
applied to the unborn as well but with
all of that said there's this weird
antipathy toward people voting for
issues that Democrats don't want them to
vote for so they're all pro-choice when
it comes to abortion but they're anti
pro-choice when it comes to everything
else they're anti choice when it comes
to religious Baker's they're anti choice
when it comes to whether you should have
to join a union or pay a union they're
anti choice when it comes to whether you
should be able to vote on issues like
abortion in general so they are utterly
inconsistent on these issues so you know
it's it's it's just it's ridiculous but
this sort of crisis mentality on the
left has been exacerbated I mean we had
a minute we had Maxine Waters talking
about violent uprisings essentially mob
justice happening a week ago imagine how
bad things are gonna get now I mean I
said to somebody in the White House I
hope your Secret Service protection is
great because I do not trust that there
aren't going to be an increased number
of nuts who are looking to kill somebody
based on the level of antenna of
politics in the modern American stem I
can't blame that on the media I'll blame
the raise temperature on the media but
I'm not gonna blame you know
assassination attempts on the media but
the temperature is just too high for
something not to blow that's that's the
direction in which this is moving and
now with all that said president from
given rally last night and president
Trump's rallies are always basically
hour-long comedy routines I don't think
the President Trump is really cooling
down the rhetoric at all and this is
what his fans love about him his biggest
fans love the fact that President Trump
likes to engage in the same sort of
fisticuffs that the left engages in and
I understand the the tendency of the
id's who do resonate to this stuff so I
think this is helping the the country
move forward in any positive way
probably not here is Donald Trump going
after Joe Crowley who was who was just
defeated in a primary by Alexandria
Sanchez hacia Sanchez II can't remember
her name the socialist 28-year old who's
the new face of the Democratic Party he
goes after Joe Crowley here's what he
had to say last night we had a great
evening because we watched that
television and we were winning left and
right they didn't know what the hell
happened and one of my biggest critics a
slovenly man
Joe Crowley got his ass kicked a
slovenly man named Joe Crowley okay I
just I love that he has to stick his
boot on the guy then first of all
Crowley was less anti-trump than the
person who replaced him but you know is
this is any of this really going to make
the country better not really sure I
also do love the the blindness of some
people to the fact that President Trump
is not exactly captain civility so
President Trump himself says can you
imagine if I said what Maxine Waters
said here's what he said Israeli last
night
Maxine she's a beauty I mean she
practically was telling people the other
day to assault can you imagine if I said
the things she said we demand that he
immediately drop out of the race
can you imagine seriously if I said that
or somebody else said that horrible what
you said I can't imagine that because it
happened a lot so while I enjoy
president Trump's comedic timing I am
going to remind people that the
President of the United States did say
things about punching people with whom
you disagree knock the crap out of him I
promise you I'll pay your legal fees on
June 30th I'd like to punch him in the
face maybe you should been roughed up
yeah the president is not quite captain
civility so before we before we say that
all of this is on the Democrats I think
a lot of it is on the Democrats but I
don't think that it is bringing down the
temperature in any real way for the
presidents of the United States to use
that kind of language all right so I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
we'll see you here tomorrow court is
hereby adjourned
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire Ford
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018